welcome to Sofia Ridge on Saturday and
this morning there is of course just one
main story after the attack on London
Bridge yesterday the attacker 28
year-old Osman Khan was a convicted
terrorist who'd been released from
prison on licence he stabbed and killed
two people a man and a woman and in the
next hour we'll get full reaction to
that as well as wrapping up some of the
other events from the last seven days in
the election campaign but first let's
take you straight down to Westminster
where we could talk to the mayor of
London city car and a very good morning
to you I want to talk to you about the
public response and the police response
yesterday in just a moment but first can
I ask you about you know that this
particular individual a man on licence
released on licence a man who who may
have been tagged we're not sure how on
earth could this happen well firstly
there's a live investigations are going
to be very careful what I say and I
mustn't breach confidences but I think
the questions you're asking are
questions that I'm asking as well there
are a big question that needs to be
answered because obviously it affects
other people who may be a source of
concern for many of us so I mean I've
been concerned for some time I've said
this publicly well as a parliamentarian
forget when I was the mayor that I think
one of the important tools judges had
when it came to dealing with dangerous
convicted criminals including convicted
terrorists was their ability to give an
indeterminate sentence to protect the
public was taken away from them by this
government and that's a concern that
I've expressed before and what that
meant was that in the past a judge could
say this person is so dangerous he or
she can't be released until he can prove
to us he's done moment of danger to the
public and that's not fair doubt and
that's a concern I've got the second
issue which is when people are released
on licence does the Ministry of Justice
does the Probation Service have the
powers and resources to properly
supervise people who are clearly
dangerous and I think these questions
will be asked about this individual to
make sure we find out what happened here
but also there are wide lessons as well
yeah I would say if we move it away from
that individual for obvious reasons when
someone has been convicted of a of
a terror attack and they are released on
licence without having to go I mean
should it be automatic do you think that
someone under those circumstances
convicted of such a crime should
actually have to go before the parole
board before getting released yeah I
don't think that it's right that
somebody's convicted of a serious
offense like what this man was convicted
of should be automatically released in
fact I was somebody who voted against
the government getting rid of the IPP
sentence I think it's really important
for judges to have all the tools at
their disposal better people have heard
the evidence well let's find out what
happened this particular case but also I
believe of course people need to be
released if they've been rehabilitated
but that is we probably supervised with
the system that is effective that are
the proper resources and that's how you
keep the public confident that the
authorities are doing all that they can
to keep us safe
are you comfortable that the threat
level was reduced just a week or so ago
I am we've got a fantastic system in
that country where politicians don't
interfere with the Joint Terrorism
analysis centre who do the expert
analysis about threat levels arising
from international terrorism and just to
reassure your viewers the threat level
used to be severe which means that
attack is highly likely it was changed
to substantial which means an attack is
likely as far as the police are
concerned the Security Service are
concerned in my experiences the mayor
nothing changed the vigilance was still
there the what you call posture from the
police and these services was still
there and so I I'm assured there's no
reason for us to be troubled by that and
just to reassure your views Londoners or
others come into London over the course
for the next few days they will see Met
Police Service officers sativa London
officers British transfer police
officers armed some you were in uniform
some plain clothes there they're not
because there's been an increased threat
or because of heightened security
they're there for reassurance and just
to make us all feel comfortable go to
our city do their Christmas shopping
ordering the bars and restaurants can I
ask you about the police response
yesterday
again it is you said earlier on it's
slightly difficult there are various
investigations underway and the
automatic investigation into someone
when they when they fire a firearm but
but what's your your general impression
of the response and the emergency
services yesterday look yesterday we saw
you know one example of the worst of
humanity this man was a terrorist a
criminal and the worst of us we also saw
the best of us we saw London as ordinary
citizens act in an extraordinary way
people who should be following the
advice and running away for their own
safety people who should be fleeing from
danger doing the opposite running
towards danger and by the way hindsight
is a wonderful thing they didn't know
that the vest he had around him with
explosives was a hoax what they saw was
a man with two knives one very big knife
there ran towards him to stop him
causing further harm and damage to other
people risking their personal safety
that's all we people without any weapons
and I'm in all of them and I think over
the course of the next few days and
weeks they need to be properly
recognized for their bravery the second
point though is your right to raise the
issue of our police officers and I and I
I'm in all of our police because I see
you in a daily basis that police
officers go to work and unlike you and
me when they go to work they know that
there's possibility that their personal
injury will be jeopardized their life
will be jeopardized and I'll tell you
this the armed response officers who
turned up almost immediately were
confronted with a man who appeared to
have a suicide vest on him they didn't
run away but it makes sure that you know
they were safe they took him out to make
sure he wasn't able to cause further
damage and injury to others and again I
I want to pay tribute to the police
officers there's really important we do
so split-second decisions I made to try
and keep us safe and they made the right
call as far as I'm concerned
of course the Metropolitan Police are
gonna be asking about the level of
support in the wake of this that they
get what can you tell them about that
and as you say with the you know extra
number of officers on the streets
providing reassurance as you say but
obviously there's there is going to be
concern about the possibility of people
getting ideas from this and obviously
Christmas is always
at a slightly concerning time they're
gonna want more support from you aunt
they and they deserve more support for
majest Mira from the government from
City Hall we're doing what we can to
support our fantastic police the
under-resourced and
overstretched I've been say of three and
a half years that the cuts from central
government I've gone way too far
and cuts are consequences we need to
make sure that we have more support for
our police counter-terror team and
others also the Minister of Justice and
information we prevent crime occurring
in the first place what I can't say to
Londoners and visitors is as far as
we're concerned were not gonna allow
this terrorist to disrupt our way of
life weren't gonna like him to spoil
Christmas we're not going to allow him
to affect our businesses in London the
good news is last night in and around
London Bridge and the central London
you had people enjoying the bars the
restaurants the sights and sounds of our
city I'm hoping many people will come to
Central and them today to shop for
Christmas we've got to make sure that we
gender a confidence our stoicism is on
display we are resilient we don't allow
this terrorist anybody else to not just
divide our communities but to stop us
leading our lives it's there a concern
that I mean we we almost have a reliance
don't we on on intelligence we it's one
of those things that goes on and we
don't really think about until someone
tells us that you know 15 attacks were
prevented in the previous year or
whatever that figure may be should we
are we in a position now where these
isolated incidents and let's hope they
are isolated have to be expected in in
major cities in this country really
important so what we do know from the
security advices that a number of cities
around the world our targets for a
terrorists the phrase used by experts in
2017 is the role of entities wasn't a
spike in relation to terror attempts
terror attacks is a shift in the
attitude of terrorists to try and cause
terror and cause damage since the for
tax in 2017 there have been 24 attacks
thoughted some from so-called
Islamic terrorists some from so-called
far-right extremist that's 24 attacks
thwarted and the police the surrey
services worked incredibly hard one of
the main reasons they're able to fought
because of the intelligence provided by
members of the public and that's why
it's really important the public's
confidence in the police and one of the
things that I'm keen to get across is
policing is all linked it's not
counter-terror here and enabled police
in there they're separate it's all
linked that's why it's really important
that we support a police not not just in
terms of the resources they need to a
decent number of officers and the
resources that goes with that but also
we members of the public help the police
so the message to the public is one be
vigilant if you see anything at all
those suspicious err on the side of
caution and report it to the police I'd
rather you over report then under report
but second let's make sure we go about
our business and don't know the
terrorists to disrupt our way of life
well you pointed out what the members of
the public did yesterday which was
hugely brave no two ways about it and
and indeed getting out on the streets of
London last night is in itself a sort of
active divided difference a very
positive move we're living in such a
divided time at the moment divided over
brexit divided over Europe divided over
the general election campaign at the
moment what can someone like you as a
figurehead I mean admittedly with your
party political allegiances but what
still is a figurehead what can you do
what do you need to do to actually bring
the people of the capital of this
country together well first you've got
to remind ourselves why we're a target
why does it man like this one attackers
is because he hates the fact that we're
pluralistic we don't just tolerate other
we respect and celebrate and embrace
each other he hates the fact that you've
got Muslims Christians Jews rich poor
Sikhs Buddhists those members in
organized faith those that aren't
members of the lgbtq+ community or
getting on together really well behaved
that and what we're going to do is make
sure we remind ourselves we're a beacon
for the rest of the world we celebrate
our civil liberties we have human rights
and they hate that
and it's really important that we you
know a confident we have the right
posture and body language to show you
know what we're going to allow you to
get us down and you know my good friend
who unfortunate along with us Joe Cox
said in her maiden speech there is far
more that unites us than divides us and
events like yesterday should remind us
of that and of course the focus of right
is going to be on this terrorist
and to learn the right lessons but I'm
keen to focus on also the wonderful and
the best of us that was the bravery of
those ordinary Londoners who did
extraordinary things that's what we
should be celebrated and I'm hoping over
the course of the next few days and
weeks leading up to Christmas people
come to London if you're not a Londoner
come to London come and shop in our
shops come to our bars in their
restaurants borrow market around the
corner from Allen bridge you know very
well has been infected or just by
yesterday but also in 2017 they're
struggling as businesses go come and
support them that's the best way for us
to be resilient and stoic and so these
terrorists they will never win